I don't believe what I just saw when
he does this he's moving doing it with
speed that's the key that is just a gorgeous
patient play dude that was insane capriso in
with speed capriso swings wide tried to Center
bounces to Johansson Johansson centers Capri
off unbelievable the thrill does it again drill
Capri off on the back back door what a play there
by Marcus Johansson 30 foot saucer lands right
on his stick and he does what he does Forsan had
it knocked away in the Blues a break again and
much davich for Kyu to Thomas to Kyu to B davich
great passing they score what a goal by B davich
look at the patience on that one there waiting
waiting waiting and just putting it behind Bob
rovski beautiful passing play all three players
touching the puck moving it around doing it with
speed as well that's the key I think I'm dizzy
after watching that that's a beautiful play John
I don't blame you here AED to the net Around the
Net pass SC the Rangers wining it over time zaban
Jad is going to be so patient hold it hold it hold
it throw it in front Lucan in the goal tender
kept thinking Zan he's got to shoot right he's
got to shoot got to shoot I'll play him like he's
going to shoot the net was wide open and krider
finishes off the beautiful pass that is just a
gorgeous patient play Real Simple speaking of we
got Swaggy P on our pregame show you saw him with
Haley's in the building tonight first intermission
Crosby to flex it in talk about sick how about SI
what hasn't this guy done all season finishes his
check in the corner and then execution jumping
past his man to the net great read by gensel
will take away the the wall and it's a bang bang
play rosby's got another goal out of the gates
Nam red hot Smith checked by bler here's Garland
on to the left wing Teddy Luger across for Dakota
Joshua Garland sores what a pass what a play
by this line again Luger to Joshua to Garland
for the taping this line just finds new ways to
impress entry on the left wing saer to the right
wing the Garland going to the Ws the net he's not
going to sweep this one in without missing Willam
me later at a 19 point streak it's Matthew score
number 26 and he scored every way possible what a
sick play that is on the sideboard look like it
as he was coming around he might go back to the
point his little adjustment just throw Skinner
and then the quick turnaround on Sanderson right
through the legs of set quick hands and no
hesitation Levi definitely didn't expect it
what a move by tarez what a goal by John tarez
one of the things that tarus works on a lot
those little tight turns but there's two beauties
and just a perfect shot I mean it's not just the
execution of the spin and then open ice but look
at how quickly backand to forehand and the release
Up and Under the bar and his son here Matias Oh
What a Beautiful backand by Mar is back to the
play and just whipped a wicked backhander he's
going to have that time and space and not only
is it a back I think it's a forehand Jeff pulls
it between the legs and roofs it it's between
two sets of legs actually it's Matias Samson
who we're just talking about he's on the body
but doesn't have the stick and it ends up going
right there past Levi top shelf Bard shoots wide
to the stick side of Bennington kurf plays the
rebound for Bard down low Bard the cross stle
scores what a play I don't believe what I just saw
otherworldly skill here as he just softly picks
that up on his stick goes up over the shoulder he
knew exactly what he was going to do takes it off
the board protects It reversed it in as a right
hand shot and tucked it by the glove we have not
seen him do that in a game situation just yet but
the kids got some marvelous hands dude that was
insane minakov brings it back in drops it off to
zis Trevor takes it in behind the that he scores
on a cross goal the thing about zis when he does
this and executes it is he's moving I've seen a
lot of guys try it but not while they're skating
at almost full speed what a beautiful play by
Tri seers I think most of the crowd is just now
realizing what he did cuz they showed the replay a
couple of times on the big board above Center ice
and the reaction got a great deal louder trying to
connect that one towards zerin Thea head here's
board shoots and score what a pass you're going
to watch it right here a turnover again has the
Kings do a nice job of stepping up Mikey Anderson
across from the other side but that pass from fiaa
it wasn't on his stick for even half a second and
he recognizes more as wide open and what a finish
Chemistry Between FAL and Moore continues to grow
amongst the brothers as Nick Felino says Zev poo
score what a pass keep your stick on the ice go
to the far post good things happen RAR gains The
Zone stops on a dime a little backand pass two
Avalanche go to him zit makes a good play to his
La play goes from Bolino to the right but it all
starts with a good entry into the zone and a good
chip in by Tyler Johnson F to line Pon got it to
the goal scores it's tipped in front by Morgan
Baron Morgan Baron does a nice job go to the
net get position ooh and it's off to stick in it
bian went through the line first suggesting that
he had the goal but it's certainly looked like
Baron got gets a stick on it right there the tip
maybe they're trying to fool the Red Wings ped
Away by Fisher fi will gra it he's got room he's
in he scores Excell yson F first of the year
I know you play cool once in a while look at
this bang Pass Perfect care joh fi stutter steps
to his right crosss the body goes back the other
way and be dmer what a beautiful pass that was
eers comes in Fr go shley RS it home and that
line de to the game look at all the wings in the
corner everybody facing the butt that leaves Mark
shley wide open perfect pass from poity dealers
with a little touch skate pass a bang bang play
that line they get chances and it's in the net
hard denied by Calvin Pickard and now a two on
one Adam Ernie with James hlin Ernie to the net
scores his first as an Oiler great play by G in
the wall here in the defensive Zone knows he has
to get this out he just has to get it out but he
puts it right on the tape of Ernie and this is
a power move to the net beautiful move to the
forehand to wrap it around Van DeAndre Miller
tape to tape saan ja nify across the line rink
wide hoping for krider he'll put it behind the
net sa a one touch back the what a play by Ma
zabad you cannot one touch a pass prettier than
that the rim comes around he angles his stick
those wheelers here and he leaves it right on
the tape E Holmes going one way Skinner can't
get over to the post cuz he thinks zad's got the
puck and Blake wheeler loves it centering pass
held up ech on the doorstep score H McDavid with
the entry just a nice pass to the middle then a
give go with Hyman and that cor little backhand
pass by Heyman he spins back into position to
open up and then goes to the backhand in tight
no chance for Jonathan Quick on that one really
because he elevated it so high he's expecting
this shot to come in the forehand as soon as he
gets this quickly to the backand boy did he put
it far in it ties this game and back and here we
are Clark scores from behind the net it's 66 he
on the goal line oh my God he's behind the goal
line it looked like it jumped up somehow and
the puck could do that with nobody touching it
was just hting a run in the ice and he just didn't
have the post coverage short side enough the puck
out to Center Colin Blackwell with another chance
stops on a dime in the slot a score what a play
lost control on the forehand had the patience and
presence of Mind as he's getting cut off to take
it to the backend but that's not it now he wakes
and wakes now I'm thinking he's going to shoot it
no slides it between the legs of Gallagher who is
looking to the skies he can't believe the blackw
just did this along the board to the point branom
down for kachuck birie kachu tried to center it
oh what a goal Josh noers FS it out of the air
one for the highlight reels branstrom just gets
the puck down low the big body of kachuck there
battling and as the puck bobbles itself out in
front I think Norris is going to clip this right
out of the air it goes up and boom right there he
just whacks it got it right across his Crest and
in through under the arm of D velkovich here's Shu
back in to the center goes ready to Chuck CHS
it in on the sh pass from for jeru the stretch
pass to jaru and he just throws the back hand
across he's throwing the puck to an area this
isn't meant to be on the stick it's meant to have
kachuck skate into it it's a very play all Kentuck
has to do is just lean the stick right on it and
Ferraro dumps it across Center picked off by bler
he's in with Oman Teddy bler centers scores
what a fake by Teddy bler to freeze with this
fake shot and oh man a pass to Oman and it's in
throws the goal tender Ferraro went down and it's
a backand right to Oman who's not going to miss
from there Rangers able to clear it out off the
boards wheeler picks it up savan to the net here's
crer save rebound score Fox with the diving play
to get the puck going pass the four Checker
now the Rangers find themselves a little bit
of room wheeler to crder for the shot beautiful
save here by Lucan but right there is mik's AB
bandad to put in another one he has been hot Wei
again couldn't get it through a stick it comes to
cockle and front score Freddy Olson how do you do
how about are pretty play by cogle and he grabs
it and he knows he's going to go sweet little
back hat between the legs no big deal the for
flying getting it done tonight look at the boys
on the bench pop top he love to see that kind of
[Music]
execution